So you've learned a lot
about retention and
how it's pretty normal to have around
40% player attention after just one day.
Ankur, why do you think so
many players leave after just
the first day of playing a game?
>> Well, it's very hard to make
a game that's engaging for everybody.
So people might leave after trying it
out and finding it's not a great fit.
For example, kids tend to have a lot
more time on their hands than adults.
So they prefer longer games
with more fun story lines.
>> That make sense.
Everyone plays games
a little differently.
So what can game developers do
to keep players interested?
>> Most successful games
have a target audience.
They know they can't appeal to everyone.
And so they focus on the specific
age group or a type of gamer and
try to design a game that is
targeted to that audience.
>> I think I have a great idea for
a game that appeals to
people around my age.
Check it out.
[SOUND].
What do you think?
>> It seems fairly simple.
Maybe you can make it harder by
adding some goals or obstacles.
>> Good idea, how about I bounce
the ball through a ring of fire and
into the goal?
>> That's more like it.
When you're thinking about your game and
deciding what it looks like and
how difficult it is to play,
you should always put yourself
in the players' shoes and think about
what will be most exciting for them.
>> Ask yourself are they younger?
Hardcore gamers or more casual?
>> Exactly, it's important to make your
game pace fit your player's skill level.
Like adding a ring of fire and
goals makes bouncing ball a lot
more challenging and fun.
>> Let's look at some examples
of game apps that do this well.